probably four or five years ago I viewed
the pain cave as like this place that
you should try to put off as long as
possible in a race like make your pain
cave be as far away from you as you can
and if you arrive to it then you just
sit in it and you try and survive the
pain cave
but in the past couple years I mean it's
just a mindset right it's like all in
our heads this thing and in the past
couple years it's been
the place I want to get to so like
changing it to a place where I get to
celebrate that I made it there and then
that's where the work actually happened
so making the pain cave bigger is how I
view it instead of like pushing the pain
cave away and I think I mean our minds
are so powerful so even just like
changing the storyline
makes it a whole different game